a matrix diagram is a tool used to
arrange and display information in order
to help you understand important
relationships and make decisions it can
be used in a number of different ways to
help you make decisions for action for
example imagine you're looking at a list
of change ideas you know you have only
so much capacity and you want to be
thoughtful about where to start you
might use a matrix diagram like this
let's draw this out so what I can do
here is basically say okay I've got my
different ideas and with my team I can
look and say well gosh let me think
about this here for a second so with
idea one on a scale one to five you know
how much do we think this this can be
done in in say a 90-day timeframe we
might look at that say oh gosh well I
can only do this may take longer than 90
days I'm not sure so maybe I'll give
that one a 2 on idea too though I think
this one totally could get done in 90
days and idea three there's probably a
high likelihood okay great well let me
think about will to fix this problem is
it's important to people i might come
here and say well you know there's a lot
of will here for an idea one there's
actually quite a bit for idea too but
idea three you know it's something that
people aren't ready to work on yet and
then as I look at things that I have
control to make changes on I might come
across okay great so there's this again
maybe it's moderate level to control the
changes this one I pretty much
completely in my control and idea a3 is
not in my control at all and then
sponsorship I look and your idea one
there's a sponsor who says that this
would make sense no look at it there's
good sponsorship for idea too and
there's kind of limited sponsorship
moderate sponsorship for idea three so
as I'm looking at my matrix now I can
kind of look at my PI data to which of
these ideas has the best chance of
success right and in this particular
case as I look across them I might
decide to select idea to
because I've got a higher degree of
belief that it's going to be able to be
accomplished in a short amount of time
there's will to improve it I have the
ability or the control to test changes
and there's good sponsorship so that's a
high spot for me to potentially be
successful in a project as you go
through the ranking you hopefully
discover that one change idea may be
better than another to start with
because it possesses more of the factors
for success it also can help you think
about where work may need to occur to
improve the likelihood of success of
other change ideas before you begin to
test them can you think of where in your
project a matrix diagram could be useful
you